So if you remember from the last lecture,
Value Propositions, what we're really
trying to do is find the right product
market fit between what you're building
and who wants to buy it. Again, we call
this relationship between value
proposition and customer segment simply, product market fit. Today, in "Customer
Segments," in this lecture, we're really
going to ask what job are we getting
done for the customer. That is, what
functional or social jobs are we going
to get done? What emotional jobs?
What problems or needs are we solving?
What gains are we providing the customer? What pains?
How does market type affect this? And at
the end, what we're going to come up with
is a deep understanding of the persona
and architect. Who are they? Why would
they buy? Why won't they buy? What do you need to say to them? And if you spend
your energy out of the building, doing
customer development and customer
discovery here, it will make your company
incredibly efficient in actually
figuring out how to market and sell to
them. So remember the goal is now to
connect the value proposition with what
you're going to know and learn outside
the building about customers.